Chemical properties: so let's put
something up as a hypothesis.
Let's say, well, maybe it has to do
with the energy that it takes to
remove electrons.
And, one other thing that I failed
to point out, if you take a look at
the energies associated with the
outermost electrons,
in this case, lithium,
you see it's 0.5 megajoules per mole,
and then what's the 6.26?
That's associated with one,
n equals one, inner shell. There is
a huge difference between the
energies in the outermost shell and
the inner shells,
which tells you that it's unlikely
that any electrons except those in
the outermost shell are going to be
active. The inner electrons are so
tightly bound that they are for all
intents and purposes,
immobilized when it comes to
reactivity. Again, boron
is a good example.
Look, 0.8, 1.36.
This is 2p. This is 2s.
Yeah, they're different but they
are roughly on the order of about 1
MJ per mole. If you go down to 1s,
it's 20 MJ per mole. So, the
chances of getting any activity from
these inner shell of electrons are
vanishingly small.
So, let's focus on the outer shell
electrons. And,
these outer shell electrons are
termed valence electrons.
So let's construct a model here that
suggests that chemical reactivity is
somehow related to the electron
binding energies of the outermost
electrons of the outermost shell.
And, this outermost shell is termed
the valence shell.
So, in a first blush,
you might say, well, why don't we
just take the first
ionization energy?
And, that's not a bad first guess.
But, we know for example that
magnesium, when it reacts,
it reacts with both of its electrons,
not just one of its electrons.
So, taking just the outermost
electron might give us some false
readings. So,
what if we capture all of the
valence electrons.
Is there some way of handling that?
Because that will take care of all
of the electrons that are capable of
reacting, none of the inner
shell electrons.
And we do so by a quantity called
the average valence electron energy.
In other words, if the average
energy of all the valence electrons.
So, let's take a look at an example.
An example of that might be,
oh, let's look at something like
oxygen. If you look at oxygen,
oxygen is 1s2, which is an inner
shell electron.
Just putting it up for completeness.
2s2, and 2p4, and so here's the
valence shell.
If I want to take the average
energy of all of those,
what I can do is go over to my data
set. Here's a data set.
There is oxygen. The 2p is 1.
1. The 2s is 3.12. So then, I
could say that the average valence
electron energy for oxygen would
then be, I've got two s electrons.
So, it's two times 3.12 plus four
times 1.31, all divided by six.
I'm averaging it over the entire set
of valence electrons which gives me
1.91 MJ per mole.
Or, in my favorite unit,
19.80 electron volts.
This is electron volts per atom.
So, how does average valence
electron energy very across the
periodic table?
Let's take a look at that.
So, we see it here. We see that it
varies monotonically from left to
right as we move along a row.
So, this is a constant n number.
Within a constant shell, it varies
from left to right,
maximally taking value at the right
extreme.
And, within a column,
it decreases down a column.
It rises up a row. It decreases
down the column.
And, the values that it takes can
be broken into three groups.
Over here in the lower left corner,
we have elements that as a group
have very low values of average
valence electron energy.
These are elements that are good
electron donors.
They are good electron donors
because the electrons aren't tightly
bound. OK, elements with low
average valence electron energy,
and here I'm saying below 11
electron volts,
these are good electron donors.
And, we call these in simple
English, metals.
And, it turns out that about 75% of
the periodic table falls into this
category. So,
the vast majority of elements in the
periodic table are metals.
And, at the other extreme,
we have elements with very high
value, elements with high average
valence electron energy.
Well, we just did the calculation
for oxygen. This is almost 20 eV,
high average valence electron energy,
greater than 13 electron volts.
So, that means the electrons are
tightly bound.
So, these are poor electron donors.
And, in fact, if any electron comes
in their midst,
they'll capture it because the
binding energy is so high.
So, these are poor electron donors
but also a good electron acceptors,
and we call these non-metals.
And you see those.
And then there is this group of
about half a dozen right down the
diagonal middle.
And, they have intermediate values.
So, when the value of the average
valence electron energy lies between
11 eV and 13 eV,
we have these elements that are
neither fish nor fowl,
and you'll see in a little bit their
unique electrical properties.
And, these are called semi-metals
or metalloids.
And, in some instances,
they can be made to behave more
nearly metallic.
And in other cases,
they behave more nearly as
insulators. So,
now with this framework,
I said that talking about these
valence electrons might give us some
insight into chemical reactivity.
What can we say about chemical
reactivity?
Well, what do we know about extremes
of chemical reactivity?
See if we can grab onto something.
We know that at one extreme we have
no chemical reactivity.
We have elements that are totally
inert, and we have examples of this,
the noble gases, dominantly inert.
I know it's possible to induce
chemical reactions,
but these are exceptions.
This is not the norm. So,
we have an inertness.
And at the other end we have
explosive reaction.
OK, so do we know anything so far
that we can point to that would give
us a departure?
And the answer is yes,
we know something about the noble
gases. What do we know about the
noble gases? They are chemically
inert. They have the highest values.
They have the highest average
valence electron energy
in any shell.
And, the electron configuration is
always ns2p6. Whatever the n number
is, with the exception of helium,
helium is the oddity because there's
only two elements in n equals one
shell. But, once you get beyond n
equals one, it's always 2s2,
2p6, 3s2, 3s6. So, we have an octet
of the electrons that seems to be
associated with chemical inertness.
Octet stability is the term applied
to this feature.
So, all right, let's go with this.
Let's say, suppose we hypothesize
that an octet of the electrons is
going to lead to stability.
Is there some place we can go next
with this? And I say,
well, let's look at something like
sodium. Let's look at sodium.
Sodium has the electronic structure
1s2, 2s2, 2p6, 3s1.
Now, that's not an octet,
but it's not far. This is the
electronic structure of neon.
So it's really sodium you can think
of electronically as neon plus the
3s1 electron. It's so close.
And, I also know something else
about sodium. It's got a very low
average valence electron energy.
Its average valence electron energy
is 5.2 electron volts,
which is a heck of a lot less than
11.
So, this is a good metal.
It's a good electron donor.
So, I've got something that's one
electron away from the electronic
structure of neon.
It's a good electron donor.
If it could only ditch this
electron, it could have the same
electronic structure as neon.
But you can't just ditch an
electron. Charge neutrality won't
allow for it. If you want to lose
electron, you have to find someplace
for that electron to go.
In other words,
for an electron donor to give up its
electron, the electron donor needs
to have an electron acceptor.
So, that's sort of half the story.
Now, let's go over to the other
side. Let's look at chlorine.
Chlorine is 1s2, 2s2, 2p6, 3s2,
3p5. The chlorine, it's not an
octet here. This is five plus two
is seven. But,
when I went to school,
seven was only one less than eight.
So, this needs only one more
electron. If it could gain one more
electron, then chlorine would be
iso-electronic with argon.
So, it would achieve octet stability.
And we know that chlorine is very
aggressive when it comes to
electrons. It's got an average
valence electron energy of about 16
eV, 16.5 eV, which is a
lot greater than 11.
So, what if we were to put the two
of these in the same room?
You've got an electron donor with a
powerful urge to become neon-like.
You've got an electron acceptor
with the powerful urge to become
argon like. What if we were to take
this electron and send it over to
here, in other words,
engage in electron transfer.
What will we achieve?
Sodium would become sodium plus.
Chlorine would become chlorine
minus. So, I've got ion pair
formation, and I've got a huge
decrease in energy because a donor
is able to express that urge,
an acceptor is able to express that
urge. And, I've achieved octet
stability in a new way.
But there's more because now I've
got pluses and minuses.
This is all gas phase.
It's all gas phase. So,
what happens if I put pluses and
minuses in a gas phase?
There is a Coulombic force of
attraction. So,
the sodium over here and the
chlorine over here,
they will be attracted to one
another. So, let's start.
So, sodium, chlorine attaches.
But there's more sodiums.
There's more chlorines. So,
maybe another sodium will attach.
And, this will go on and on and on
without limit.
So, what's the consequence of
forming these gas ions?
These gas ions, if you take gas
ions, these gas ions,
if you take gas ions, gas ions of
opposite charge will necessarily
agglomerate without limit.
And, what happens if I put a
gazillion of these things together?
What's the resulting form? The
resulting form is a solid.
A solid will form. So, if you
start with sodium vapor and chlorine
gas, electron transfer will occur.
And you will form a crystal of
sodium chloride as a result of this
need to form crystal expressed
through the Coulomb's Law.
So now, I want to take a look at the
energetics of that.
Let's look at the energetics of
Coulomb's Law.
I want to talk a little bit sort of
at a general level about modeling.
How would I model this system?
Well, there's levels of models.
And, the bottom line in modeling is
make it only as complex as you need
to. Don't put in extra bells and
whistles if it's not necessary.
So, for example,
if I have a sodium ion over here,
and I have a chloride ion over here,
where the distance from center to
center I'm denoting as r,
this is nucleus to nucleus
separation. And let's say that
sodium has a radius,
r plus, and chlorine has a radius,
r minus, when r is very large in
comparison to the radii of the ions,
I don't need to draw them this way.
I can model this whole thing as
point charges.
I can model it as point charges.
This is a point that's negative,
and this is the point that's
positive. And,
that's all we need to do.
And, a lot of the derivations you
will see in physics rely on this
being able to model as point charges.
But, what happens when these two
start to get really close together?
When they start getting close
together, there is more complexity.
More complexity takes on this form.
So now, let's get a sodium here,
and the chloride ion next to it to
the point where they are touching.
So now, I'm going to show some fine
structure. Yeah,
this is net positive.
The sodium is net positive.
And the chloride is net negative.
And so, there is an attractive force
between the two of them,
the positive and the negative.
But, let's look more carefully.
Sodium is net positive. But, I've
got a nucleus with 11 protons in it.
And, I've got ten electrons around
it. And, here,
I've got 17 protons in the nucleus.
And, I've got 18 electrons around
it. So, when we get really close
together, granted,
there is a net positive negative
charge with a Coulombic
force of attraction.
But, can you see that as you get
really close together the negative
electronic cloud surrounding the two
ions start to sense one another.
And, there is a mutual repulsive
force here. There is a repulsive
force, the attractive force between
ions of opposite charge is offset by
a repulsive force due to electron
cloud interactions.
This is the clouds or the orbitals,
electron cloud interactions. And,
this is what prevents them from
collapsing into one another.
They reach a certain equilibrium.
So, what we're going to do now is
look at the energetics associated
with that. And that's given as
follows. I want to plot energy in
the system as a function
of interatomic spacing.
So, the x axis is interatomic
spacing, and the y axis is energy.
Positive energy is repulsive, and
negative energy is attractive.
And, I'm going to put the sodium
atom at the center.
So, here's sodium. And,
I'm going to ask what happens when
chlorine comes in.
So, we'll put chlorine over here.
So, this is the chloride ion. It's
over here. And,
we're going to look at what happens
as the chloride ion moves from
infinity in towards the positive ion.
So, let's first go with the
attractive because you know this
already. The attractive energy is
just the potential energy,
Coulombic potential.
That's simply q1,
q2 over 4 pi epsilon zero R.
And, q1 is equal to the charge on
sodium. q2 is the charge on
chlorine. So,
this is positive E on the sodium,
negative E on the chlorine over 4 pi
epsilon zero R,
which is going to give us minus E
squared over 4 pi epsilon zero R.
And, this is just a rectangular
hyperbola, and it's going
to look like this.
So, this is the E attractive.
At infinity, there's no stored
potential energy,
and it drops off more and more
negative as one over R.
Now, how about this repulsion
between electrons?
This is not a Coulombic force.
It's very different. The repulsive
term goes as some constant lower
case b divided by R to the n.
N is not the quantum number.
N is a power law factor in here.
And, it's given by what is called
the Born exponent.
And, it's a very high number.
Why is it a high number? Because
it has to drop off precipitously.
When you get one over R, you get a
gradual fall. If you get one over R
squared, it'll be a little steeper.
One over R to the sixth will come
in, and then jump off precipitously.
And that's what you want because the
electron repulsion is only felt when
you are in really,
really close. And then,
it's, for all intents and purposes,
falls to zero. So, the Born
exponent typically takes values of
between six and 12.
And, B is some constant that we
have to determine.
So, what's one over R to the 8th
going to look like on this scale?
It's going to look like this. It's
going to hug the x axis until it
gets a very, very close.
And then, it's going to take off
like a shot. So,
this is the repulsive energy term.
And so, what's the net energy?
The net energy is the sum of the
repulsive and the attractive.
And, see, out at very, very high
separations, it's essentially all
repulsive, excuse me,
all attractive. And at very,
very low separations, it's all
repulsive. And in between,
it goes through a minimum. And,
this minimum here is what gives us
the value of the inter-electrode
separation, the inter-ion separation.
And so, I need to cheat a little
bit on the drawing and make sure
that this minimum occurs right here.
OK, so R minimum,
the minimum separation occurs when
the energy is at its minimum.
And, that's given by the balance
between the attractive force of the
ions offset by the repulsive force
in the electronic shells.
And, what we will do next day is we
will look at the consequences of
such an energetic set up,
and rationalize that when ions form,
by necessity we must form ionic
crystals.
So, I think with that I'll shift
over to some external matters.
We've seen so far that we can have
a neutral plus neutral sodium plus
chlorine goes to cation plus anion.
That's what we've just been looking
at. And this occurs in order to
achieve octet stability.
Well, it's possible to reverse this.
It's possible to take the cation
and anion and restore them to their
neutral states.
So, for example,
in an electrochemical cell,
it would be possible to take the
sodium ion, give back its electron,
and convert it into a metallic
sodium, take the chloride ion,
remove its electron, and restore
chlorine gas. So,
this is what goes on in an
electrolysis cell,
and it works thanks to input energy
from a power supply shown here.
So, that's point number one.
Point number two is that ionic
solids at high temperatures make
ionic liquids.
So, one such ionic liquid is
magnesium chloride.
Magnesium chloride is the raw
material for the production of
magnesium. This is magnesium.
It's the lightest of the structural
metals. It's got a density of about
1.76 at room temperature.
For comparison,
aluminum is 2.7.
So, aluminum is about 50% denser
than magnesium.
Steel is 7.87. So,
this is about a quarter of the
density of steel.
So, if you could make automobiles
with a high magnesium content,
you would reduce the mass, reduce
the energy required,
and thereby reduce the environmental
impact. Clearly,
if I did nothing more,
but I took every car, doubled its
fuel economy, its emissions would go
to 50% of what they are now,
no other changes being made.
So, fuel economy and environmental
conservancy make a lot of sense if
you care about such things,
of course. So, here's magnesium.
It's very light. It takes energy,
and this is how it's made.
Electrolysis of magnesium chloride
in a cell where the one electrode we
would make magnesium.
The other electrode, we'd make
chlorine gas. So,
the question becomes,
well, what are the resources for
magnesium? Do we have
magnesium to do this?
So, I went to the library and I
looked up Advances in Molten Salt
Chemistry volume six because there's
an article in there about the
chemistry and electrochemistry of
magnesium production.
So, I went to go look up the
authoritative source on this,
and so I looked this up, and I want
to give you a sense of what the
truth is. People tell you that we
are resource constrained,
that we are running out of resources.
Well, think about this.
Where are the data? A cubic
kilometer of seawater,
go into the ocean and imagine a box
1 km x 1 km x 1 km.
That's a cubic kilometer.
It contains an million tons of
magnesium, 1,000,
00 tons, which is more than has ever
been produced in one year by all the
magnesium plants in the world.
Annual production of magnesium is
about 600,000 tons per year.
You get that out of 1 cubic
kilometer of seawater.
And, seawater contains only 3.
% of the total magnesium present in
the Earth's crust.
So, clearly magnesium resources are
ubiquitous and virtually
inexhaustible.
There's lots of magnesium.
So, if magnesium is so abundant,
why is it so expensive? Steel is
about 10 cents a pound.
Aluminum is about 70 cents a pound.
And magnesium is over a dollar a
pound.
Why is it so expensive?
It's not because of scarcity.
It's expensive because the process
by which we produce it is energy
intensive and resource intensive.
So, if we want to get more
magnesium into the marketplace at an
affordable price,
not by government edict,
what do we have to do? We have to
invent a process,
a chemical extraction process that
will make the production of
magnesium cheaper so that we will
have the opportunity to avail
ourselves of energy-efficient
materials.
And so, maybe somebody in this room
working with me will invent such a
process. All right, I'll
see you on Friday.